ترسل الولايات المتحده والمانيا وفرنسا
مدرعات قتاليه الى اوكرانيا وافضل ما يمكن
القول عن هذا السلاح وانه يفتح فصلا جديدا
من العمليات العسكريه في الحرب
بشان البرادلي وما تقدمه فهي مدرعه
وتستطيع نقل الجنود في ساحه المعركه دعما
للهجوم والدفاع وتضمن من خلال القوه
الناريه والحمايه تقدما في ساحه المعركه
فيما الاوكرانيون يدافعون عن ارضهم
شاهدت الحرب الاوكرانيه في بدايتها معارك
بين الجنود الروسي المهاجرين والاوكرانيين
المدافعين استعمل فيها الاوكرانيون
الصواريخ الغربيه قصيره المدى ضد الدروع
والمروحيات
في المرحله الثانيه تلقوا مدفعيه دقيقه
استعملوها لقصف مراكز القياده والسيطره
الروسيه ودمروا عمليات الامداد الى الخطوط
الاماميه
بنات القوات الروسيه خلال الاشهر الماضيه
خطوط دفاعا طويله لحمايه جنودها ورسم حدود
جديده داخل اوكرانيا لكن الاوكرانيين
يستعدون الان لاختراق هذه الخطوط
التي تشبه الدبابات الخفيفه ستردموه في
قدرات اوكرانيا الهجوميه
بتقدير العسكريين الامريكيين سيتلاقى
الجيش الاوكرانيه
الهجوميه قبل الصيف المقبل وهو يستفيد
خلال الاسابيع المقبله من منظومه الدفاع
الجوي
لحمايه اجوائه ومن المدرعات للقيام
بالعمليه
لقاء الخطوط الحاليه يضع روسيا في موقع
يسمح لها باعاده التجمع واطلاقه هجوم جديد
من مواقع افضل مقارنه مع العام الماضي
تعبر نوعيه الاسلحه الامريكيه والاوروبيه
الى اوكرانيا على ان قادت الغرب وفي
مقدمتهم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم
يقبلوا الامر الواقع في شرق اوكرانيا وسوف
يساعدونا الاوكرانيين على اسقاط الخطوط
التي بناها الجنود الروس